allora buonasera parleremo proverò a
parlare di resilenza il sud però
allargherei prima il concetto perché
vorrei parlare del sud come parte per il
tutto alla resilienza da quello che
stiamo capendo dovrebbe essere la
capacità di adattarsi ai traumi e
sopravvivere e forse questi ultimi anni
sono stati un po più traumatici anche di
quello che che ci aspettavamo il xxi
secolo è iniziato io che voglio dire a
me dicono sempre giovane scrittore anche
se ciò 42 anni ma auguri un piedino nel
novecento cielo è il ventunesimo secolo
credo che ci aspettavamo sarebbe
cominciato in maniera un po diversa
il sostegno di cordate dopo la 89 dopo
la caduta del muro di berlino qualcuno
confida ottimismo dice che che la storia
era finita dopo un filosofo giapponese
fukuyama descrisse un libro che si
chiamava la fine della storia
ci dissero che tutte le storie erano
state raccontate ma che questo però non
era così importante dal momento che
l'umanità al risolto si disse nel 89
tutti i suoi problemi e noi avevamo
guardato i cancelli oltre i quali
cominciava il regno millenario della
pace universale
ora io ogni volta che sentono parlare
diventino millenario metto mano a robert
musil e charlie chaplin
ma all'epoca ci si riempì la bocca di
strane categorie astrologiche non so se
vi ricordate questa parola età
dell'acquario si dicevano dal tenore
stiamo per entrare nell'età
dell'acquario
scaduto il mondo diviso in due blocchi
sta per iniziare si diceva un epoca di
pace e prosperità benessere è infatti
soltanto 23 anni dopo ricomparvero i
campi di concentramento in europa a
pochi chilometri da qui non scoppiò la
la guerra nella ex jugoslavia allora se
il secolo precedente era finito presto
ed era iniziato tardi no il grande
storico eric hobsbawm
parlando del novecento lo definì secolo
breve perché invenzione in ritardo con
lo scoppio della prima guerra mondiale e
14 e fin in anticipo nell 89 con
col muro di berlino il ventunesimo
secolo è iniziato subito ufficiosamente
forse iniziato proprio nel 92
ufficialmente già all 11 settembre del
per dirla con bob dylan però rovesciando
il senso si capiva che tempi che
tempestavano stavano cambiando è stato
molto puntuale il xxi secolo nel
ricordarci insomma che la violenza
l'istinto di prevaricazione erano delle
cose da cui non c'eravamo per niente
emancipati ancora ancora emancipata però
questa situazione non riguarda soltanto
le guerre non riguarda soltanto il
terrorismo non riguarda soltanto il
sangue riguarda anche un altro tipo di
violenza che si è consumata intorno a
noi in maniera più silenziosa e tante
però forse ha inciso ancora di più sulle
nostre vite sei ditte di noi di noi
occidentali
pensate a quali ritmi che sono ritmi
ottocenteschi in alcuni casi addirittura
pre moderni si è allargata in questi
primi 15 anni del xxi secolo
la forbice fra ricchi e poveri tutti gli
15 anni sono stati difficilissimi per
quello che riguarda temi come
l'uguaglianza sociale il diritto al
lavoro la ridistribuzione delle risorse
ed è ricchezze prendiamo l'italia di
qualche mese fa la notizia
avrete letto sui quotidiani che le dieci
famiglie italiane più ricche possiede un
patrimonio pari a quello dei 20 milioni
meno abbienti guardate la classifica dei
più ricchi nel mondo quest'estate
abbiamo tutti quanti tribolato davanti
alla crisi greca ma il patrimonio delle
23 persone più ricche del pianeta e
trentino private non aziendale su draghi
gran lunga il debito greco
le prime 90 persone più ricche del
pianeta detengono una ricchezza pari a
quella dei 3,5 miliardi
i più poveri 80 quanto 3,5 miliardi a
questi ritmi del 2017 dicono appunto gli
statistici da rick detenute dal famoso 1
per cento supererà quella del restante
il 99 per cento nel piatto ma facciamo
un esempio italiano per capire come sono
cambiate le cose non vi ricordate
l'azienda proprio del novecento italiana
fiat vittorio valletta
ve lo ricordate a di fiat anni cinquanta
e sessanta il suo stipendio era parte a
dalle 40 alle alle 60 volte con la tv
il rapporto fra marchionne e un suo
dipendente è pari a 500 a 1 quindi da 70
1 a 501 qualcosa è andata per il verso
sbagliato perché si può chiudere sul
fatto che una disuguaglianza colmabile
con la concorrenza contribuisca a tenere
viva anche dal punto di vista una
società
possiamo discutere però quando sta
andando la violazione dei diritti umani
non è lontana di una società è
squilibrata e si sta scrivendo sempre di
più più una porzione via via maggiore
dei suoi componenti vede ridursi
partecipare a etico di parte di una
comunità difendere la sua tragicità e
infine e infine sopravvivere sembrano
cose scontate sembrare sembravano come
dire concetti acqui entro però insomma
così pacifica questa non è stata allora
adesso mostrerò troppo con una una foto
una foto sul lavoro no harvard business
school e dan ariely della duke
university talora vengono incrociati in
questa in questa foto che tra poco
comparire eccola lì tre parametri il
modo in cui il 92 per cento dei
cittadini americani quindi sia
democratici che repubblicani per quanto
riguarda insomma la fede e politica
vorrebbe che fosse distribuita la
ricchezza nel paese c'è questo è quello
che la cosa in basso quello che
vorrebbero il 92 per cento degli
americani
il secondo parametro è ciò che secondo
loro c'è loro dicono va bene vorremmo
che fosse questo però purtroppo e
quell'altro più in alto invece è
l'effettiva l'effettiva come di
redistribuzione della ricchezza negli
stati uniti
allora il risultato appunto è
sorprendente perché oltre nove decimi
degli interpellati vorrebbero che il 20
per cento dei più ricchi avesse una
ricchezza si superiore ma non superiore
a quella del 40 per cento dei più poveri
con il doppio
il doppio va bene e al di sotto di
quelle della classe media gli stessi
interpellati sono convinti questa è
l'idea è invece quello di cui sono
convinti che quel 20 per cento possiede
invece poco più della metà dell'intera
ricchezza del paese è invece la
situazione reale va oltre il pessimismo
del 92 per cento idee americane e che
quindi vorrebbero una redistribuzione
delle ricchezze completamente diversa da
quella che è anche quelli che votano
repubblicano
il grafico successivo e adesso compare
eccolo lì a questo grafico è un altro
modo di leggere le disuguaglianze negli
stati uniti però il discorso non è
diverso da tanti altri paesi a
capitalismo avanzato
l'italia è uno dei paesi più squilibrati
per esempio dell'unione europea
e allora immaginate un paese composto da
100 persone no queste sono 100 persone
immaginiamo che ci siano solo a queste
100 persone i mattoncini verdi
rappresentano la ricchezza dell'intero
paese ecco vedete guardate lo squilibrio
fra singole teste e mattoncini verdi non
per cento c'è l'ultimo vino a destra
quello li detiene più ricchezza degli
altri 99 messi insieme
così come anche i primi 90 uomini tutti
questi qua a loro volta hanno meno
mattoncini di quanto ne posseggono i
penultimi 9 poi l'ultimo è come dire è
scandaloso in tutto questo il novecento
è stato è stato il secolo delle grandi
trasformazioni tecnologiche in certi
casi le trasformazioni tecnologiche
hanno portato hanno portato anche a più
democrazia
qual è stata la grande rivoluzione
tecnologica del xxi secolo quella che
riguarda l'elettronica non la rete è
arrivato internet che tutti quanti noi
utilizza utilizziamo adesso consentitemi
di raccontarvi un aneddoto personale
privato 18 anni fa era il 1997 fresco di
lauree in giurisprudenza qui a bari e
andrea milano a frequentare un corso in
tecniche editoriali fra i docenti di
questo di questo corso nel 97 quindi
veramente un'era fa c'era la
caporedattrice di un'importante casa
editrice milanese che non vi dico come
si chiama ma come l'ha ribattezzata
ribattezzata la signorina magnifiche
sorti e gli diceva stanno per arrivare
le magnifiche sorti e progressive perché
diceva ragazzi voi sarete anzi gli
ultimi sarete i primi che lavorerete
nell'editoria con le nuove tecniche noi
usavamo le tecniche di composizione fino
a qualche anno fa
insomma che si sono utilizzate per
decenni voi utilizzerete finalmente
questo programma arrivato il computer
nell'editoria si chiama quarkxpress
quartics e il programma con cui lavora
nell'editoria lo sa sim pagina qualunque
cosa vuoi imparerete a impaginare con
questo programma utilizzerete il
computer lavorerete così noi in casa
editrice che lo stiamo utilizzando da
qualche tempo utilizzando lo risparmiamo
il 25 per cento del tempo non soltanto
ragazzi di se la signorina magnifiche
sorti esiste uno strumento magnifico si
chiama email era 97 al celebre mela oggi
sembra scontata la cosa all'epoca non lo
era esistono questi mesi se questo
programma che si chiama world e pensate
gli autori non ci mandano più il
malloppone che ci dobbiamo poi ribattere
tutto qua ci mandano direttamente alcuni
alcuni i più giovani diciamo così ci
mandano il file word noi lo produciamo
in lo schiaffo in quad press
e così facendo risparmiamo un altro 25
per cento
mi complimento dicevamo non alle gigi
proietti e tutti quanti eravamo
strabiliati da questo finché l'unica
persona intelligente del corso che non
ero io ero una ragazza alzo la mano la
ragazza molto carina come sono carine le
ragazze coraggiose e intelligenti anche
quando non sono carine sono carine lo
stesso che disse scusi professoressa si
ma
vi pagano il 25 per cento di più no
lavorate il 25 per cento di meno
non ho anzi lavoriamo anche di più ma
guardi scusi allora vi stanno fottendo
era chiaro c'è un aumento di
produttività a cui non corrisponde un
aumento di stipendio non corrisponde una
diminuzione del lavoro è chiaro che gli
stanno fottendo oppure se la volete
mettere su un altro punto di vista e
quindi uscendo tranne detto personale su
un giornale neomarxista che si chiama il
corriere della sera è uscita questa
quest'estate questa questa la base della
differenza fra l'economia
come dire fra l'economia del ventesimo
secolo e del xxi secolo
negli anni 60 general motors non era sul
corriere della sera a general modo sei
anni sessanta raggiungeva i 7 miliardi
di dollari di fatturato per dire di
ricadi pardon ogni fatturato 7 miliardi
di dollari di ricavi dando un salario a
600 mila dipendenti
quest'anno apple guadagnerà circa 80
milioni di euro miliardi di euro
occupando 92.600 persone ridotta
all'osso
a differenza fra capitalismo la seconda
metà del ventesimo secolo ed è a inizio
del xxi secolo è tutta qui allora se
questo è lo scenario al punto spalancato
del xxi secolo persino no pensate anche
con gli a quanto di come che ogni volta
che mette un contenuto su facebook mi
rode un po il culo perché vado ad
arricchire col mio contenuto zuckerberg
però insomma in zai che a sua volta è un
pigmeo rispetto ai grandi colossi
finanziari così che persino uno che è
cresciuta in un epoca post ideologica
come la mia guardando questi primi me
dire questi primi a liti di xxi secolo
gli viene voglia di rispolverare
berthold brecht no quando diceva che
rapinare una banca un crimine ma meno
grave che averla fondata allora la marea
si sta alzando la maria si sta alzando
velocemente e se qualcuno resta con
l'acqua alla gola prima degli altri
non è perché gli altri si salveranno ma
perché occupava il lato del
transatlantico dove l'acqua arriva prima
per esempio la grecia per esempio noi
per esempio il sud
allora questa estate sono arrivati dati
svimez no a dirci che siamo messi male
che tanto hanno fatto tribolare il
nostro presidente del consiglio
un coccolone qualcuno ha avuto la
tentazione di dire che esistono due
italie e qualcun altro in maniera ancora
più imprudente ha parlato di cultura del
piagnisteo anche se negli ultimi anni si
è molto più parlato di questione
settentrionale che di questione
meridionale
ora non ci sono due italie e o
dell'europa che non capisci il sud non
capisce d'italia non capisce l'europa e
non capisce neanche il mondo perché il
sud è spesso l'appunto la cartina di
tornasole dell'intero c'è il luogo in
cui le contraddizioni di un intero
sistema di un intero paese
esplodono con più forza l'italia ha un
piano industriale che fa pietà
poi c'è una città che si chiama taranto
in cui questo appunto disastro assume le
proporzioni più scandalose in tutta
italia c'è una disoccupazione giovanile
che fa vergogna nel sud questa
contraddizione qui esplode in maniera
più forte che altrove quindi è la parte
per il tutto quindi veniamo alla
resilienza la residenza a punto e tutto
questo in questa per non parlare appunto
del fatto che cosa dei diritti dei
lavoratori appunto al sud si torna a
morire nei campi come esempi di giuseppe
di vittorio una presenza inquietante che
proprio in puglia sono morti quest'anno
dei braccianti per il capolarato del
caporalato insomma come diceva umberto
eco questi primi anni del xxi secolo
sono un po a passo di gambero allora
stavo dicendo veniamo alla resilienza
dovrebbe essere una risorsa importante
per affrontare la viola e la tempesta
che si sta scatenando su di noi
ora la resilienza sarebbe la capacità
appunto abbiamo detto di adattamento
attraverso cui è possibile sopravvivere
agli eventi traumatici e tuttavia per
venire fuori tutti interi da questa
tempesta o almeno non morti anche un
pochettino ferite ma non morti tempesta
che investirà tutti noi non soltanto il
sud non basterà a saltare su una
scialuppa di salvataggio o cercare un
salvagente o trovare un rifugio sicuro
dove attendere che passi la nottata
perché nottata non passerà se aspettiamo
che passi la nottata con tutto il
rispetto per eduardo non confondere
insomma la parola resilienza con la
parola resistenza eco resistenza non
intendo la resistenza della guerra e
partigiani quale un altra roba è il
nostro grandissimo patrimonio però non
come dire farei la resistenza
col culo degli altri cioè con il cioè
con chi ci ha preceduto lasciamola perde
della resistenza che in alcuni casi può
essere un alibi per non mettersi in
gioco c'è per dire resiste resistiamo
mettiamoci le mani in testa e aspettiamo
che passi la nottata per dirla con il
titolo di un famoso romanzo di walter
siti da questo punto di vista resistere
non serve a niente
non serve trovare riparo o aspettare che
il mare si calmi perché non si calmerà
tutta tutta la prima parte del xxi
secolo potrebbe essere una lunga
tempesta vorrei allora che la parola di
silenzi ecco questo è l'augurio avesse
oltre alla capacità di adattarsi alla dc
alle difficoltà un valore attivo proprio
c'è che sia sinonimo di azione e non
soltanto di ripariamoci di mettersi in
gioco di innovare di immaginare nuove
forme di comunità di politica di
convivenza di modelli economici e
culturali
non si tratta insomma lo dico ancora una
volta di ripararsi dalla tempesta con il
poco che si sa si tratta di immaginare
un nuovo tipo di imbarcazione per
solcare appunto la tempesta perfetta del
xxi secolo e mettersi al lavoro subito
realizzarla grazie